the most immediate value from the
cognitive surplus comes from satisfying
of intrinsic desires right the kind of
things that we're motivated to do that
are different from my boss told me so or
this is what I'm paid to do and they're
both personal and social motivations
intrinsic motivations have both personal
and social components personal
motivations tend to be autonomy and
competence right the idea that i'm the
author of my own actions or that i'm
good at something social motivations
tend to be membership in generosity I'm
part of a like-minded group that
recognizes me and accepts me as a member
or my activities are creating benefits
for other people who are grateful for
the work I've done so the primary value
driving all of this stuff is really some
positive sense of self that comes from
participation in public action whether
it's whether it's personal or social as
long as enough people want to get some
of that value out of uploading photos to
flickr you know uploading for uploading
videos to YouTube uploading pictures of
cats to i can has cheezburger those
those aggregations those aggregations
will do well damn stream from that
there's a whole range of questions about
value right so the the the value of i
can has cheezburger calm was the
purveyor of lolcatz of the of the
pictures of cute cats with cute captions
completely slight right not not not
world-changing not really doing much
other than giving people something to
laugh at at a coffee break the value of
Wikipedia you know it's in less than 10
years has become the most important
reference work in the English language
so on that range the range of kind of
social utility downstream of the
participants you've got everything from
really nothing more than you know a bit
of fun on a work day to reshape people's
sense of what's possible
you